this is campaign check and we're
examining the claims and counterclaims
made by politicians out on the election
trail let's start with a number
you've probably heard before 20,000 new
police officers the Conservatives making
this recruitment drive 20,000 extra
officers over three years the
centerpiece of their law and order
offering at the election they say is an
unprecedented boost but is it really
let's take a look at the numbers and if
you look back 40 years you can see how
police numbers and englishdom wells rose
and rose before falling dramatically in
this territory years after 2010 from
about a hundred and forty thousand down
to around 120 thousand so what are the
Conservatives plans well we know the
Home Office is now planning to have an
extra six of that 20,000 total officers
in place by 2022 21 that implies finding
an extra fourteen thousand in a single
year 2022
that would be an enormous recruitment
drive raising some question marks about
whether it's actually possible now
presuming they can pull it off total
police numbers would you can see be back
to the level they were before
austerity Corral right well maybe
because we remember the populations
grown over that period so those officers
are having to protect and serve an ever
bigger number of people so what happens
if you divide them by the population
well this actually even after you've
added those 20,000 of them the total
number of officers per hundred thousand
people around England and Wales is still
well below where it was for most of the
80s than 90s and the early 2000s how
would that make us look compared with
our European counterparts well England
and Wales would switch still at the
moment has one of the weakest police
forces by this measure in Europe might
go up one maybe two countries in this
leaderboard but it will still be quite
near the bottom of the table it's worth
pointing out there both Scotland and
Northern Ireland fare much better than
that
but there's another question do these
numbers actually make a difference the
link between falling numbers of officers
and the increase in crime is clear as
night and day we've seen an increase in
knife crime we have an epidemic across
the whole country in knife crime we've
seen it very very difficult for ordinary
people to get police officers to read
a crime no so if if people are watching
now the chances are that some people who
have had a crime will find it extremely
difficult to get a hold of a police
officer and then it's very very
difficult to get the police officer to
investigate the crime most recent
figures from the crime serve F England
and Wales show crime levels were fairly
flat in recent years after a steady fall
since the mid 90s but there's a more
mixed picture if you look at particular
types of crime so take knife crime which
in England has increased by 41% over the
last four years that's according to
hospital admissions data still the next
time you see that twenty thousand
numbers worth remembering that while
it's certainly a big boost in real
population adjusted terms it doesn't
even reverse many of the cuts made
during the austerity period